I'm in meetings a lot.
My calendar gets very full with those.
And then at night, after the kids have gone to bed,...
...I'm on email a great deal.
I get messages during the day.
That's my chance to give long responses and then, over the weekend,...
...I send a lot of mail as well.
I take two weeks a year to just go off and read and think...
...where I'm not interrupted by work or anything else.
I'm just solidly trying to think about the future and...
...people get to send me things to read as part of that so-called "Think Week,"...
...so it's a nice mix of things.
About 25% of the time that I'm out, traveling around,...
...meeting with customers in Europe, Asia.
And that sort of helps me think, "Okay, do we have the right priorities?"
What are people responding well to...
...and what would they like to see us do better?